you've had
quite a few problems haven't you with
the menopause talk us about to us about
your experience
well very briefly i didn't have any of
the the physical problems you know you
talk about hot sweats and so on i should
say i'm coming up to 62 years of age and
post menopause now so this happened
about
10 years ago when women um
didn't really or were made to feel
ashamed when they talked about the
menopause they were meant to feel as
though they were going crazy as though
you're having a funny turn you know all
of that terrible language that's that
was associated with it and shouldn't be
and um i found i started to become
anxious
which i've never been in my life you
know i run businesses i fly a plane all
of that kind of stuff and it you know
where was this coming from and then that
developed into a very serious deep
depression and i had no other issues
going on in my life i had a very happy
life i loved my life
um
and i used to keep uh a log and it was
my savior really of the day my period
started every month
and i started to see that there was a
pattern
and that it was linked hormonally i
found a private doctor who put me on
hormone gels and which are now available
on the nhs
and within 48 hours those feelings have
disappeared and i spoke about it on itv
about six years ago and it kind of broke
a taboo you know all these things you're
not meant to mention
um and i'm glad i did mention it but i
really worried at the time about talking
about it and that's ridiculous isn't it
it's ridiculous
you know when these things can be
resolved so simply
did you feel isolated
uh i did at the time because everything
you know i was hosting blue swimming a
few years earlier on itv
and whenever the girls talked about oh
yeah you you were the language is very
important you know the language you were
meant to use was sort of
self-deprecating and degrading to you as
a woman yeah oh i'm having a crazy day
or one there's that in the other you
know why should we have to use this
stuff it's just a hormonal imbalance and
and so i have deep objection to the way
we use language about it um and women
should stand up i was
doing a piece of television yesterday um
alongside the menopause bus and one
woman lives in cardiff and woman came
down and she said i was sacked last week
i was i'm a chef i was sacked last week
because the manager was bullying me and
said i was forgetful all the time what a
terrible thing to happen and this
happens all the time so for good you
know good for caroline everyone involved
really who um
are putting this menopause workplace uh
pledge into into action it's very very
very important
yeah what's your advice um carol to
women who and men who are watching this
morning who are anxious
are unsure about how to deal with the
menopause and the symptoms and the
impact that it has not just on the
person that's going through it but of
course uh work colleagues um and indeed
family as well
i think to find as much information as
possible to fill in the sort of lists of
symptom checkers
to insist that you have your blood test
because only by the blood test can you
see where your levels of the particular
hormones are balanced
get some sort of hormone replacement if
that's what you your doctor advises but
um
you know to to tweak it because the
first thing you know some people say oh
i had the patch it didn't work but
that's perhaps because that balance of
it wasn't right for you i tweak all the
time as i i'm going through the years
you know what what suited me when i was
53 doesn't suit me now i'm 61 because
your body changes quite dramatically so
i would say that that is very important